I think were social networking we've
only seen the tip of it I think it is
going to be so mega huge and in terms of
marketing when I deal with celebrities
now probably half of what I deal with is
their media image their appearance the
other half is websites and web chats and
their Facebook and their twitters and
things like that because that's how
younger people communicate I agree with
you I'm not that interested that Tammy's
having coffee or running to the
drugstore because you know she has a
rash on her arm it's not that
interesting to me but it sure seems
interesting to a lot of younger people
out there you know i'll be at a party
and i'll see a young person in the
corner and I saw with my nephew oh my
nephew was at a party and he's in his
20s and everybody's talking and
socializing having a drink and having a
good time and he was texting I'm like
excuse me come into the present tense
but that was his present tense in if you
have kids and there's a little boy in a
little girl in a sandbox and the girls
playing with her doll and the boyfriends
playing with his dump truck but they're
ignoring each other we call that
parallel play we're seeing a lot of
parallel play in our society right now
we're seeing that people can be at one
place and twittering their friends that
oh I'm at this party there's this hot
chick the foods not very good where do
you want to meet afterwards as opposed
to being in the moment and I'm afraid
being in the moment can be lost
you